there's so much we didn't know about
this place Henry
world upon world entire civilizations
far more than we ever see you giveth you
take it away very quickly but I want to
know
she spent what 30 years in the quantum
realm yes okay I got to know some basic
things like how she survived and what
she ate and where she slept okay food
does it there's a lot of food options
down there we don't really explore the
restaurant scene in the quantum realm so
much in the movie but I imagine there's
great restaurants down there exercise
routine is really just survival down
there what can I say without getting a
Marvel assassin shooting me for spoiling
yeah like what did she do for fun to not
go completely insane these are the
questions I have well we you know we'll
see one scene in the digital thing the
quantum realm I'll take that we cut out
of the movie there's a thing where she's
she and Hank are traversing the quantum
realm and they come up on this quantum
creature and instead of course like
fighting it and killing it she
communicates with it so he gives you a
little hint that she has some skills
some diplomacy skills that she's put to
use in the quantum realm so yes she's
been busy yes she has some power down
there he does around and she did gain
some powers so I have to know is the
idea to explore these in a future film I
hope so yeah I mean who knows hopefully
we're gonna get to do a third goal we
honestly don't know yet but we
definitely have a lot of ideas things
that we've certainly set up in this
movie but she's had a very
experience now there's a thing you you
mentioned that because Marvel is always
in motion but I have to know it is there
a plan in your head of what a trilogy
our way to wrap up the ant round story
there is yeah and there's a lot of stuff
you know as we were writing the second
one and coming up with things we're
going to set up we definitely had ideas
for character arcs for all the
characters and I certainly have some of
my own somewhat which I've shared with
Marvel someone haven't but I really
really hope we get to further their
story
me too and final question because I got
to let you go now that we're in a post
infinity world what do you think of the
Internet's you can hold a podcast
well it's typical internet right of
course that's it's um it doesn't
surprise me
anything can happen online and you know
he is pretty hot you can get past the
chin thank you my great sure well he's
got we've got we've got someone I've got
like a fan of chin no you need like
several more yeah that's another thing
well thank you so much thank you okay do
one bring it on cheer and then we're
done cold in here Wow there must be some
Toros in the atmosphere I'm sorry
clovers
[Applause]
[Music]